grâce à votre journal de l'afrique sur
france24 toute l'actualité du continent
c'est maintenant bienvenus ravi de vous
retrouver le mystère en afrique du sud
21 corps sans vie ont été retrouvés
dimanche dans une boîte de nuit du sud
du pays aucun signe de blessure
apparente la police ne privilégie aucune
piste fin des discussions à conakry le
premier ministre a reçu dirigeants
politiques et acteurs de la société
civile
objectif une transition apaisée nous
verrons cela avec mme annick diakité a
des talents multiples un parcours
atypique une vie qu'il a menée au
sénégal en france et aux états unis à
travers son objectif il confronte le
présent au passé et rend hommage aux
femmes africaines le photographe à
l'ondé notre invité bonsoir à tout à
l'heure
que s'est il passé dimanche dans un bar
d'islande donne dans le sud de l'afrique
du sud 21 jeunes ils sont morts les
survivants les survivants évoque une
odeur suspecte
une équipe d'enquêteurs spéciale a été
dépêchée de pretoria on attend les
résultats des autopsies se fit la mode
des familles en pleurs inconsolable
certains âgés de seulement 13 ans fêtait
la fin des examens
nous avons le coeur tellement brisé nous
avons perdu un membre de notre famille
un enfant qui était encore au collège
nous ne pouvons pas l'accepter
nous sommes l'une des familles les plus
pauvres et aujourd'hui nous demandons
justice parce que nous ne savons pas ce
qui s'est passé
la police explique tous les jeunes était
en train de danser tombée avant de
décéder un par un
les corps ont été retrouvés sur le sol
de la taverne sur les tables et les
canapés des autopsies sont en cours
parmi les hypothèses un empoisonnement
collectif ou une intoxication
selon certains médias les agents de
sécurité du lieu aurait bloqué les
portes et gazé les jeunes à l'intérieur
le propriétaire de la taverne explique
que ce soir là la situation a dégénéré
dans son bar
les loups et les vigiles m'ont appelé
après une heure du matin en me demandant
de venir ici car il avait des
difficultés à contrôler les gens
il y avait trop de monde et ils
n'arrivaient pas à les contrôler
certains voulaient sortir et d'autres
voulaient entrer de force de l'extérieur
même quand on leur disait que c'était
plein à l'intérieur
l'enquêté se poursuit et les parents
pointent la police du doigt qui n'aurait
pas dû laisser les mineurs entré dans le
bar ni consommer de l'alcool il appelle
à des contrôles plus stricts dans le
pays l'un des plus gros consommateurs
d'alcool au monde
lentement et espérons le sûrement un
dialogue politique s'amorce en guinée
presque toutes les formations répondu
présent à l'appel du premier ministre
mohamed béavogui nommés par la junte il
s'agit de mettre sur pied une transition
apaisée la correspondance de madine qu'à
quitter
les débats ont duré pendant près de
quatre représentants de partis
politiques société civile les religieux
mais aussi des diplomates accrédités en
guinée étaient présents les échanges ont
été présidée par le premier ministre de
la transition mohamed béavogui selon lui
les objectifs de cette rencontre sont
très clairs faire un diagnostic sans
complaisance et surtout proposer des
solutions pour une transition je cite à
plaisir et inclusive
l'objectif est de mener ensemble une
transition apaisée vers un retour à
l'ordre constitutionnel
je puis encore vous rassure et de ma
détermination
celle de mon gouvernement et du cndd et
de son président à travailler avec vous
afin de mêler ce dialogue de façon
constructive et efficace à la sortie de
la rencontre les représentants des
partis politiques qui s'attendaient à
des propositions concrètes se disent
déçus c'est une déception totale parce
qu'on s'attendait pas à ça nous avons
passé la journée toute la journée si on
pensait que le premier ministre à la
sortie d'ici alain prennent un
engagement à les voir le corps et du
mooie meid un cadre du dialogue pour
qu'on se retrouve autour de la table et
discuter vous avez
ils nous appellent pour parler longtemps
c'est ce qu'on avait fait le 4 septembre
nous avons été le 14 septembre on abat
le blabla tous les partis politiques qui
se sont exprimés ils nous ont demandé de
faire des mémos nous avons fait des
mémos qu'ils ont mis à la poubelle nous
attendions mieux voilà voilà celle de
sebha voilà le sud est eût cette
rencontre s'est déroulée sans la
participation du rpg rassemblement du
peuple de guinée du président de sue
alpha condé le parti exige tout d'abord
la libération des anciens cadres du
régime de ceux qui sont encore en prison
avant de prendre part à tout dialogue
dont le pays
niger burkina faso mali bénin ou encore
sénégal tous contribuer activement au
trafic mondial de drogue le rapport
présenté par l'onu ce lundi à abidjan
est sans appel l'afrique de l'ouest et
du centre n'est plus une zone de transit
et de forte consommation explications de
notre correspondant en côte d'ivoire
samuel bernard alors de nombreux
éléments dans ce rapport on retient en
particulier l'importance de l'afrique de
l'ouest dans le trafic mondial de drogue
et en particulier le trafic de cocaïne
en effet entre 2019 et 2022 ce sont 57
tonnes de cocaïne qui ont été saisis
autre élément d'importance les
trafiquants ne vise plus les pays les
plus défavorisés les plus pauvres mais
au contraire les pays les plus intégrées
les plus développés écoutez à mama do
philippe deslandes reste directeur
régional de l'onu d'essai pour l'afrique
de l'ouest et le centre les criminels
qui veulent s'établir qu'est ce qu'ils
cherchent un état de droit fort
des autorités compétentes ont
digitalisation dans le système bancaire
il ciblait les pays forts comme la côte
d'ivoire qui sont qui me guide qui ont
une progression économique forte la côte
d'ivoire est en effet traversé par ces
trafics en avril dernier ce sont deux
tonnes de cocaïne qui ont été retrouvés
dans les ports de san pedro et d'abidjan
depuis une enquête est en cours les
autorités ont procédé à une trentaine
d'arrestations visant des personnalités
du monde économique mais également de la
police une chose est certaine la lutte
contre le trafic et la consommation de
drogues sont loin d'être terminée
puisque le rapport prévoit une
augmentation de 30 à 40 % des usagers de
drogues sur le continent
kinshasa a accueilli ce lundi le
cercueil de patrice lumumba dernière
étape du périple mémorielle du héros de
l'indépendance le premier premier
ministre du pays a été assassiné en 1961
de sa dépouille ne reste qu'une dent que
la belgique a restitué lundi dernier à
la république démocratique du congo un
deuil national a été décrété jusqu'au 30
juin date à laquelle aura lieu la
cérémonie d'inhumation jour de la fête
nationale
c'est dakar qu'il l'a vu naître en 1980
mais dès sa plus tendre enfance
notabilité et ballotté entre l'afrique
de l'ouest la france et les états unis
des études d'architecturé imposé par un
papa et maman est une passion la
photographie kiné pendant l'adolescence
il en fait son métier et en 2015 la
consécration ses oeuvres sont montrées
pour la première fois au public l'expo
universelle de milan puis viennent la
biennale de dakar ou encore le musée du
quai branly ici à paris notre invité
c'est vous allen b bonjour merci d'être
avec nous que parcours parcouru depuis
donc 2015 est votre première exposition
on va y revenir ces études d
architecture je lisais c'était le choix
de vos parents la seule architecture que
l'on découvre dans vos dans vos photos
ici à l'écran c'est celle de deux
visages pas de monument pourquoi avoir
choisi de portraits teese est
essentiellement et pas de photographier
des monuments par exemple ben en fait je
dirais que j'utilise énormément
larchitecture normes à photographier
même si je sais les portraits de deux
visages j'utilise des principes
d'architecturé la structure ainsi que
donc finalement fait ses études m'ont
aidé dans mon mon parcours artistique
sait jamais si loin finalement
l'architecturé la photographie ça
nécessite la créativité la de la rigueur
de la technique évidemment oui non les
deux sont très très lié dans les deux
cas on essaie d'encastrer la lumière
soit entre des murs soit dans un cadre
photographe chutant alors avec les
visages que l'on découvre à l'écran le
but de cette exposition c'était
empowering women c'était en 2000 à 15 c
est une série à qui vous a fait
connaître je le disais pourquoi montré
des visages d identité c'est une manière
de montrer que l'afrique est bien
multiculturelle c'était surtout pour
aller au delà des clichés qu'on a sur
l'afrique parce que l'afrique est
souvent montrée comme
soi c'est la guerre soit c'est la
famille soit c'est où on va à l'opposé
de ça soit c'est la musique la danse les
sourires le foot le sport mais l'afrique
en fait il ya 50 millions de nuances
entre ces deux extrêmes et donc je
voulais montrer ces femmes comme ces
femmes fortes comme des personnages de
même en manoeuvre de new york times
magazine c'est c'est ça c'est de faire
ressortir finalement le pouvoir
peut-être cacher des femmes africaines
on serre les nombreux pays étaient des
sociétés matriarcales sa disparu
désormais c'est ça c'est de remettre un
peu au goût de jour le pouvoir les
pouvoirs de ces femmes c'est exactement
c'est assez de m ces femmes les sociétés
matriarcales été très présente en
afrique et il n'y a pas que ça il y
avait aussi
l'afrique était déjà très plonger dans
la la science quantique et
l'environnemental donc en fait toutes
les choses écologique en fait qui touche
le monde occidental était déjà très
ancrée en afrique on va découvrir une
autre série
édification c'est en 2017 deux ans après
donc vous mêlez là
le présent le futur plutôt même et le
passé on voit des enfants avec des
casques de réalité virtuelle
voilà on les découvre certains de vos
clichés mise en scène dans des rites
d'initiation là encore quel est le
message c'est une manière de dire que la
technologie et n'est pas incompatible
avec le passé l'héritage culturel
c'était surtout en fait comme vous
l'avez si bien dit ce sont des rites
d'initiation à la vie donc du coup
chaque photo représente
cette visite paris d'aller très très
très peur celle à laquelle d'ailleurs de
la série et pour moi il représente en
fait la prise de conscience de sa
potentialité et c'est exactement ce qui
est en train d'arriver à l'afrique en ce
moment on est en train de reprendre
possession de ces de son patrimoine
immatériel et ceci nous donne un certain
élan pour se retrouver notre place sur
sur la planète aedifica les chaînes
édification ça marche aussi en français
s'est dit fier brique à brique
financière à pierre l'afrique ce recoin
bolivien à l architecture effectivement
un message aux jeunes aussi peut-être
n'oubliez pas votre passé malgré les les
technologies oui c'est à dire qu' il
faudrait avoir un regard sur sur
l'avenir mais nos racines notre notre
héritage culturel
et traditionnel est aussi important que
ce regard qui est porté vers l'avenir
alors on parlait du rôle des femmes on
voit que la défense des droits des
femmes est un combat de longue haleine
évidemment loin d'être gagné on l'a vu
encore avec l'actualité récente aux
états unis vous vous y avez vécu aux
états unis on le rappelle à la cour
suprême qui a décidé de ne plus garantir
aux femmes le droit d'avorter
oui qu'est-ce que ça vous en
recul en recul tout simplement et mais
c'est important de continuer de fête ccc
plus de mouvement et on doit juste
poussé dans le bon sens lorsqu'il a
commencé à vous entendre ça ne va pas à
la dent dans le bon sens avec cette
décision de la cour suprême alors je le
disais biennale de dakar il ya eu
l'exposition universelle de milan il ya
eu le quai branly à paris quelle est la
prochaine étape je crois si mais si mon
petit doigt
bon que ça se passe du côté du mexique
exactement là donc la prochaine étape
après avoir fait aussi l'asie maintenant
on va en fait rencontrer l'amérique
latine qui pour moi en fait là pas tant
de différences avec le continent
africain et
on va pouvoir représenter le sénégal au
mexique à tijuana quand vous dites on
sait vous en l'occurrence c'est moi vous
seul qui allait représenter le sénégal
au mexique fin c'est pour fêter donc
cette collaboration de plusieurs années
entre les deux pays qu'est ce qu'on peut
vous souhaiter à part beaucoup de succès
de continuer sur cette lancée bas que
les droits des femmes puissent
s'améliorer dans le monde partout dans
le monde et vous inspirez peut-être une
nouvelle série absolument merci beaucoup
ellen v d'avoir été l invité de ce
journal de l'afrique c'est avec vous
qu'on referme cette édition vous restez
avec nous d'autres informations
évidemment tout de suite sur france 24
[Musique]